So last time we introduced a new idea and the new idea was that of best response
and that was what was the idea.
The idea was that I think to think of a strategy that is the best you can do
given your belief about what the other people are doing,
what your opponents are doing,
what other players are doing.
And you could think of this as,
you can think of this belief as the belief that rationalizes that choice.
So if you have a boss,
you might want it a he or she is going to ask you why you chose the action.
You did a,
if you took,
if you look at best response to some belief,
you can say,
I took this action because I believed other people are going to do this.
And since that was the best you could do under that belief,
that will hopefully keep your job.
All right.
And I promised that today we would look at the most important game in the world
and as announced last time,
the most important game is the penalty kick game.
So this is a game that occurs in soccer.
And just to give it an idea of how important it is for those people who are
unfortunate enough not to be soccer fans here.
Uh,
the last World Cup was decided on penalty kicks.
In England's case,
uh,
England goes out of every single world cup and every single European competition
because it loses on penalty kicks usually to Germany.
It has to be said,
um,
and uh,
more minerally.
Uh,
this weekend,
uh,
it was all of your thinking,
the most important event in the world,
but was whatever was happening in Congress to do with Iraq.
Actually the most important event in the world was taking place in England where
my favorite team,
Portsmouth,
we're playing Chi,
the head ta,
his favorite team,
Liverpool.
Uh,
and uh,
about a third of the way through that game there was a penalty and I'll let you
know what happened later.
So keep in the back of your mind.
That's
the real world example that matters here is Portsmouth versus Liverpool this
weekend.
Uh,
Chi.
The head ta is Scandinavian,
so I've got no idea why he supported Liverpool anyway,
but I think maybe he spelled it like this and something had to smash.
All right,
so what we're going to do is we're going to look at some numbers,
but approximately,
uh,
approximately the problems is just scoring when you kick the penalty kick in
different directions.
But just make sure everyone,
do I need to explain what's going on here.
I mean,
does it everyone familiar with the situation?
There's one guy who's going to run up and kick the ball,
the goalkeepers sending and the goal and the aim is to kick it into the goal.
Is that that,
that's fair enough.
You've all seen this,
right?
If you haven't seen this,
go see it and he's come on.
This is all right.
So things you should do in life.
And I read Shakespeare and cs soccer game.
Okay,
so the rough numbers for this are as follows?
No,
actually they turned on the car.
So I'll give you some more accurate numbers,
but this will do for now.
There are three ways.
The goal,
the attacker could kick the ball,
he could kick the ball to the left,
the middle or the right.
And I shouldn't just say here,
here,
of course.
I mean,
all right,
this is [inaudible],
but if I get that wrong going on,
please forgive me for it.
And the goalie,
the goalie can dive to the left or the right in principle,
that gold,
he could stand in the middle.
We'll come back and talk about that later.
All right,
so this is the guy who was shooting
a shooter and this is the goalie.
And these are roughly,
uh,
well let me let,
let me put that up,
the payoffs for this game and I explain them.
So you'll notice,
but I'm just going to take,
put in numbers here and then the negative of the number.
Okay.
And the numbers are roughly like this for mine is forced numbers four minus
four,
nine minus nine six nine six six one six nine minus nine and four minus four.
And the idea here is that the number four represents 40% chance of scoring.
If you shoot the bull to the left of the goal and the goalkeeper dives to the
left.
All right?
So the payoff here is something like,
uh,
you,
one of left,
if the goalkeeper dives to the left is equal to four,
by which I mean
there's a 40% chance of scoring.
All right?
So the,
the number for the shit that the payoff for the shooter is his property of
scoring and the payoff for the goalkeepers.
Just the negative of that just to keep like,
keep things simple.
Okay?
Now,
as I said before,
for now,
we'll ignore the possibility that the goalkeeper could stay budget.
Alright,
so how should we start analyzing this important game?
Why don't we start with the idea as we learnt already several weeks ago now,
or more than a week ago,
which is the idea of dominant strategies.
Does either player here have a dominated strategy that's either plan to have a
domination strategy?
Okay,
no,
it's kind of clear that they don't,
uh,
let's just look at the shooter for example.
So you might think that maybe,
uh,
um,
maybe middle dominates left,
but notice,
uh,
that uh,
the,
the middle middle has a higher pay off against left for shooting for the left
than she did the left.
It has a lower pay off if the,
uh,
if the goalie dives to the white matter,
not surprisingly in this game,
it turns out that if the goalie dives to the left,
you're best off shooting to the right second best officers into the middle and
worst off shooting to the left.
And if the,
if that's a good to go today,
it's the left go the right your best,
best off shootings at the left.
Second.
Best off,
shouldn't the metal and worst off a shooting with the right.
And that's kind of common sense.
Okay.
So if we,
if we had stopped the class after the first week,
we're,
all we learned to do was to lit,
was to delete dominated strategies.
We'd be stuck.
We'd have nothing to say about this game.
And as I said before,
this is the most important game.
So that would be,
that would be bad.
That'd be bad news for game theory,
but luckily we can do a little bit better than hat.
Before I do that,
let's just take a poll of the class.
How many of you,
if you were,
if you were playing for,
I guess it's going to be America,
which is a sad thing to start with.
Never mind.
You guys are playing for America and you're,
you know you're taking this penalty kick and it's the,
it's the last kick in the World Cup.
How many of you,
show of hands,
how many of you would shoot to the left
and how many of you would just shoot to the metal?
Yeah.
And how many of you would shoot to the rights?
We've got kind of an even split.
They're pretty much an even split.
All right.
And what,
assuming again,
we're going to assume these are the correct numbers and we're going to see if
that even split is really a good idea or not.
Alright,
so how should we go about thinking about this?
What I suggest we do is we do what we did last time
and we started to draw
a picture to figure out what my expected payoff is.
Depending on want,
I believe the goal is going to do so this is the same kind of picture we drew
last time.
So on the horizontal axis,
this is my belief
am I believe is essentially the probability that the goalie dives to the right.
I know I did last time.
Let me put in two axes to make the picture and we'll easier to draw.
So this is zero and this is one and you probably have lions in your notes,
but I don't.
So let me just to help myself a bit.
So this is two,
four,
six,
eight 10.
So this is going to be two,
four,
six,
eight,
10 and over here.
Two,
four,
six,
eight,
ten two,
four,
six,
eight,
10.
This would be the basis of my picture.
All right.
So does it start with the possibility of shooting to the left?
All right,
let's do this.
Uh,
in,
uh,
red.
All right,
so I shoot to the left and the goalie dives to the left.
My payoff is what?
All right,
it's,
it's for all right.
If I,
if I issue to left and there's this and there's no problems here,
the goalie dive in to the right,
which means that they dive to the left then,
then,
then my payoff is for meeting.
I score 40% of the time.
All right?
If I shoot to the left and the goalie dives to the right,
then I score 90% of the time.
So my payoff is 0.9 by the way,
why is it 90% of the time and not 100% of the time?
I could miss,
I could miss.
Okay.
I could miss that happens rather often.
It turns out,
well,
10% of the time.
All right,
so,
and we know this is going to be a straight line in between.
So let's put this line then.
All right,
so watch,
it's the expected
payoff to play or one of shooting to the left as it depends on the,
see the fast,
the goalkeeper dives to the right.
All right.
And conversely we can put in,
well,
let's do this.
Assume in order,
so middle.
So if I shoot to the middle and the goalkeeper dives to the left,
then my payoff is points six is it six or I score 0.6 at the time?
And if I shoot a shoot in the middle and the golden goes to the right,
it's still,
I still see a score 60% of the time.
So I once again,
it's a spray straight line in between.
So this line represents the expected payoff of shooting to the middle as a
function of the problem.
See?
But the goalkeeper dives to the right.
All right.
And finally do it in green.
Let's look at the pay offs.
Expected payoffs.
If I shoot to the right,
so if I shoot to the rights and the goal today is to the left,
then I score with probability 0.9 or a payoff is nine.
Conversely,
if I shoot to the right and uh,
he or she dives to the right,
then I score 40% of the time.
So here's my pay off 0.4 and
here's my green line.
Representing my expected payoff
as the shooter from shooting to the right as a function of the problems that the
goalie dives to the right.
All right.
Did everyone understand how I can start to this picture?
It's actually easier picture than the one we constructed last time.
All right,
so what does anyone notice from this picture?
What's the first thing that jumps out at you from this?
But assuming these numbers are true,
what jumps out at you at this picture?
I think we get some,
some mics up here.
So,
uh,
can we get this guy?
But it was stand up first.
The guy in red,
what's your name?
It looked at the hold.
The Mike.
Just a shout.
Oh,
Steven.
And um,
there's no point at which the six shooting it,
the middle is,
gives a higher expected payoff and exactly.
Exactly.
So the thing that I hope jumps out to get this picture is this.
No,
no.
Great guesses.
We're figuring out this is a half.
So if the,
if the problems are that the goal is going to jump to the right is less than the
half,
then the best you can do is represented by this Green Line,
which is shoot to the right.
All right,
so the gold is going to shoot to the right and with the property less than a
half,
she's gonna dive for the right to protest to the half.
You should shoot to the right.
And conversely,
if you think the gold is going to shoot to the right with property more than a
half than the best you can do as represented by the pink line and that shoot
into the laughter.
If you think the goal is going to die for the right withholding more than a
half,
the best you can do,
your best response is to shoot to the institute,
to the left,
and there is no belief there's nobody you could possibly hold given these
numbers in this game that could ever rationalize shooting the ball to the metal.
Is that right?
All right,
so no 10 all the way.
Middle is not
a best response to any
belief.
I can hold about the goalkeeper,
but anybody.
All right,
so there's a lesson here.
I just put you on.
I'm going to do it.
Just a Mick lesson.
Resonant Games.
Again,
imagine that you are in the World Cup.
You're playing for England.
All right?
You have to justify your actions,
not only of your teammates,
uh,
bots to your and your manager and your boss,
but to about 60 million rather angry fans.
All right.
And what's the lesson here?
Yeah.
Oh,
hoping it was going to be obvious.
What's the lesson here?
Okay,
the last one is,
all right,
lastly,
do not shoot to the middle.
All right?
Do you not shoot to the metal?
Let me qualify that lessen slightly
unless you're German.
Alright,
Jim is going to do whatever they like.
Alright.
No,
it turns out that about a third of the game,
uh,
between my team,
Portsmouth and case Tim Liverpool this weekend,
uh,
there was a panel teapots without a panel fee.
And the guy who's gonna take the penalty came up to get the penalty and he
kicked it to the middle and it was saved.
All right,
so just confirming this,
these actions,
uh,
not only does that spoil my weekend,
but it also spoiled my opportunity to make fun of Kyle Week.
So it was really a big deal.
All right,
so this weekend a penalty was missed exactly by somebody's ignoring this rule.
All right?
There's a more general lesson here and the more general lesson is,
of course,
do not choose a strategy that is never a best response to anything you could
believe,
right?
The more general lesson,
do not choose a strategy.
Do not choose a strategy.
Vat is never
a best response
to any
belief.
I notice here to submit,
just to underline something just came up at the end last time.
That doesn't mean beliefs of the form.
The goal is going to die of laughter or the goal is going to dive right?
It means all provost is in between.
All right?
So we're allowing you to,
for example,
to hold the belief that it's equally likely that the goalie dives left or diets,
right?
Yeah.
All right?
But if there's no belief that could possibly justify it,
don't do it and underline what arises in this game.
Notice that in this game we're able to eliminate one of the strategies.
In this case,
the strategy of shooting into the middle,
even though nothing was dominated.
All right,
so when would of domination and deleted dominated strategies?
We've got no way here.
Here at least we've got somewhere we got rid of the idea of students in the
middle.
Now if you could just persuade the English and Portsmouth soccer players at this
lesson,
I'd be very happy.
All right,
before we leave and I,
I've been making a point in this class,
I've coming back to reality from time to time.
So this is a very simple model of the soccer game in reality.
And let's just try it.
Any of you on the a Yale soccer team?
No.
How did you play soccer for your college?
Well,
let's see if I took of course.
And have you ever played like how many of you have ever played soccer?
Oh,
okay,
good.
Okay.
I was going,
I was getting worried there for a second.
All right.
So one thing we said last time was when we,
when we,
when we put up a modal and try and draw lessons from it,
we should just take a step back and say,
what's missing here?
What's missing here?
So let's try and get some kind of deal.
I'll come off the stage and make it easier for Jude.
What's,
what's missing here?
What's missing in this model of this piece of soccer,
this game within a game.
What's missing here?
Why is,
why is this not necessarily a hundred percent accurate models?
I'll need some mics up here.
Mark,
can you,
you have to really shock cause you're miles from the mic that you might be
better at kicking to the left or to the right depending on whether you're right
handed or left handed.
Good.
So one thing that's clearly missing here is I'm ignoring that.
In fact,
right footed players find it easier to shoot to that left,
which is actually the goal is right.
Yeah.
All right.
So right for the players find it easier to shoot,
to,
uh,
to the left is spacing.
We should have crossed the goal.
Right?
Is that true?
Everyone confirm that's true.
Yeah.
I want to,
his driver tried to do this.
It's a little easier to hit the ball hard to the,
to the opposite side from the fiber Jeff,
which is your foot.
And that's,
that's the same principle in baseball.
It's a little bit easier to pull the ball hard than it is to hit the ball to the
opposite field.
All right.
Uh,
yes.
okay.
Players don't make their decision before and didn't just stick with it
necessarily.
All right,
so play as I'm making a decision as that running up.
I think that's okay here,
right?
We can,
we can think of this as the decision happening at the instant to which you
kicked.
All right?
So your rights that you could have made a decision back in the locker room or
you could have made the decision that halftime,
but the ultimate ultimately what?
Wow.
I'll definitely,
what matters.
We're getting that off there,
so,
okay.
It's hope that goes away.
We're sure it's off my mic
just in case.
I'll move my mic a bit lower.
Alright.
So I'm going to,
I'm going to shout louder cause my mic is now a now lower.
It doesn't really matter exactly when the decision is made.
Right.
At the end of the day,
the goalie doesn't know the decision of the,
of the shooter and the,
she doesn't know the decision of the goalie.
So it's as if that that decision made instantaneously as the,
as the shooter was running up.
All right,
what else?
What else?
Yeah.
Can we get this taken?
You can I get this guy here that stand up,
stand up
shutout.
The goalie might stay in the middle.
The goatee might stand in the middle.
That's a good point.
And of course I've,
I've extracted from that here.
Uh,
and in fact we'll come back.
I think I'll try and put that onto our problem set.
But I think you're right.
It is a,
it is a,
it is an issue.
Here is an issue here.
Uh,
anything else?
What did we put up?
Some real numbers and we'll see you have it.
Uh,
how much the corresponds to what we've got here.
Okay.
So I gave you some numbers I made up actually a long time ago.
But since,
since I've been using this game in class,
somebody went out and checked and it turns out that ignoring middle for a
second,
ignoring metal.
So these are real numbers
and these numbers come from a paper in the ar by Kia Pori and some coauthors.
And for the,
uh,
everyone at Yale,
I'll make that paper available to,
uh,
through j daughter through the,
through the air library.
So you can go look at it if you like.
And what they worked out was the following,
the following table,
uh,
and uh,
again,
uh,
it will be a little bit careful here.
So I'm going to put the left and right and inverted commerce here because
actually what they did was they corrected for people's natural direction and not
natural direction.
So the idea here is,
uh,
shooting to the left if your rate footage is the natural direction.
So left here means the natural direction.
Of course,
if your left foot,
it goes the other way,
but they've corrected for that.
All right.
And it turns out that the problems is of scoring here are as follows,
63.6 94.4 89.3 and 43.7 all right.
To things are not,
and I haven't given you the numbers for the metal,
but so you can see that whoever it was who said you're slightly better off,
you score with slightly higher prevalence is when you kicked your natural side
is exactly right.
I think are things belong dominated and we could still have done exactly the
same analysis and actually,
see I'm not,
I'm not very far off,
uh,
in the numbers I made up.
All right?
But things are not perfectly symmetric.
I forget who it was who said that,
but that's,
uh,
that,
that doesn't have to be true.
All right.
Uh,
certainly the garlic staying pushes an issue or as I,
we'll deal with that on the problem set.
But there's another issue here.
Let me just raise one more issue.
One more issue is you haven't,
you have another decision when you run up to hit this hit the penalty other than
just left and right.
So when he's played the game,
what's the other decision you really faced?
The w taking to get the woman here?
Other decision you face
up to the top corner and the lower you could kick up and down.
That's true.
That's true actually.
But I,
I mentally out if that's right,
but that makes me a house.
What else is the,
um,
uh,
the striped,
try this guy here.
Spin.
Well,
that's getting subtle.
That's getting stuff done.
So much more basic thing.
What's a more basic thing?
What's a more basic thing here?
Uh,
they're gonna get there right in front of you.
Yep.
Speed.
Right?
So another decision you face is do you just try and hit,
kick this ball as hard as you can or do you try and place it all right?
That's probably,
uh,
that's probably as important to decision as placing it as,
as,
as deciding which,
which direction to head.
And it turns out to matter.
So,
for example,
if you're the kind of person which is,
I have to say all I ever was all kinds of,
if I'm the kind of person who can kick the ball fairly hard but not very
accurately,
right,
then it actually might change these numbers.
All right?
If you can hit the ball very hard but not very accurately,
then if you try and shoot to the left or right,
you're slightly more likely to mess.
On the other hand,
as you shoot in the middle until hitting the ball hard,
you're slightly more likely to score.
Now,
if these all seems like arcane and irrelevant detail,
let's just see why this matters in the picture
and then we'll leave soccer at least for the day.
All right,
so if I,
if you're the kind of person who can kick the ball hard but not accurately,
then it's going to lower the prices of scoring as you kick towards the the
rights because you might miss and it's going to lower the probability of scoring
as you hit towards the left because you're like to the mess and it might
actually raise the privacy of your scoring as you hit towards the middle because
you get the ball so hard,
it's really pretty hard for the goalkeeper to stop it.
All right,
and here's the air,
it goes in the middle.
If you look carefully there didn't really make it clear enough.
You can see suddenly suddenly our strategy that looks crazy shooting for the
middle of a sudden they started to seem okay.
All right.
It turns out there's dotted lines.
There's an error in the middle,
just the area between here and here and this little area here.
You actually might be just fine shoot into the metal.
All right.
So in reality,
in reality,
we need to take into account a little bit more and in particular we need to take
into account their bonuses of players to hit the ball at currently and or hard.
And if those people,
if you're interested in that,
and I wrote us this one,
I probably lost the interest of most Americans in the room,
but for the non Americans or the Roman people who are interested in the real
world,
um,
that,
uh,
I,
I as I said before,
I'll put that article online and that goes through all the gory detail of this.
All right.
I'm not sure,
just say the dates are,
I just gave you is real data,
but it's actually a mixed ability data.
This data comes half from the Italian league,
which is pretty good.
And half from the French league,
which socks?
So yeah,
so who knows how much we should trust it.
All right.
Okay.
So that was our example of the day and our first brush with Ralph's d for the
day,
let's clean board and do some
work.
Do some,
a bit more formal stuff.
Yeah.
So here we have,
uh,
an example,
but I want to go back to the generality and a bit of formulas.
Oh,
by the way,
I should tell you that the game ended nil nil or zero?
Zero.
Yeah.
Not yet.
It's a moral victory for me,
I think.
All right,
so I want to be formal about these things I've been mentioning informally and in
particular I want to be formal about the definition of a of best response.
And I'm gonna put down two different definitions of best response,
one of which corresponds to best response to somebody else playing a particular
strategy like left and right.
And the other,
which is going to correspond to the,
to the more general idea of a best response to a belief.
All right.
And I'll do it.
It will allow us to use on a rotation and just be a little bit more nerdy.
So player eyes strategy.
Okay.
Plant ISCM strategy s I hat get a hat.
It just a single it out is a best response.
Always abbreviated br two.
That's strategy s minus sy.
Oh,
the other players.
Okay.
All the players.
If,
and here's our real excuse to use Australia annotation.
If the payoff from player I from choosing s ihat against s minus sy is weekly
bigger van,
her payoff from choosing some other strategy s prime against s minus PSI.
And this better hold for all es I prime available to play high.
All right,
so in previous,
uh,
definitions,
we've seen the qualifier for all beyond the other player strategy here.
The qualifier for all is on my strategy.
All right,
so a strategy hat has the best response to this strategy.
S I s minus I of the other players.
If my payoff from choosing essay hat against desk minor,
sy is weekly bigger than that from choosing s I prime,
uh,
against that I,
I at Osi and this better hold for all possible other strategies I could choose.
And there's another way of writing that that's kind of useful
or equivalentlys
I hat souls the falling,
it maximizes my payoff.
Okay.
Just mine.
I'm hoping everyone is used to seeing the term Max [inaudible] salt of the
maximization problem.
How do I maximize my payoff given that other people are choosing?
S minus.
All right?
And again,
for the math,
the Roman don't panic.
This is just writing down in words what we've already seen a couple of times
already today.
Well today and last time it's generalized this definition a little bit since we
wanted to allow for more general beliefs.
So rewriting plat eyes strategy.
Same thing as I hat is a best response,
but now let's be careful.
The best response to the belief
PE about
the other players
choices.
Hey,
finish look remarkably similar except now I'm going to have expectation if the
expected payoff,
the player I from choosing Sei has given that she holds this belief p is bigger
than her expected payoff
from choosing any other strategy
given.
She holds this belief p and this better hold
for all as I prime that she could choose.
All right?
It's a very similar idea and the only thing is I'm slightly abusing notation
here by saying that my payoff depends on my strategy and a belief.
But what I really mean is make expected path as the expectation given this
belief.
All right?
And once again,
we can write it the other way.
Or S I hat
solves
Max and I choose SSI to maximize my expected pay off this time
from choosing sai against.
Nice.
My last line.
And what do I mean by expected pay off?
Just in our example,
I just make clear with that expectation means.
So for example,
the expected payoff to player one and the game above from choosing
left given she holds the belief p is equal to the probability that the
goalkeeper as to the left times play ones payoff from choosing left against
left,
plus the probability that the goalkeeper dives to the right
times play a one to expected payoff from choosing left against.
Right.
Okay.
So expectation which recipe just means exactly what you expect it to me.
All right,
so this is a little bit of math over the formality.
Is everyone okay with that?
I haven't,
I haven't a thing here.
I was on his right down slightly.
Boringly a nerdily exactly what we already saw in a couple of occasions.
Okay.
Ah,
thank you.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Bye.
Thank you.
All right,
so that right now he's going to seem a little bit like sudden blast of of
notation.
So let's,
let's just remind us that what we really care about is the idea.
It's not an invitation and let's spend the next half hour applying these ideas
to an application.
This application is not as in as important as soccer,
but it's a bit more economic seat so I can justify it under the economics title
of the class.
Yeah.
All right.
It's a clearing off my soccer game.
Yeah.
So imagine we're going to look at it as a game involving a partnership
partnership game.
And I believe this game is covered in some detail in the Watson textbook or
something very close to it is if you,
if you're having trouble,
the idea is this,
there are two individuals who are going to supply an input to a joint project.
So that could be a firm,
it could be a law firm for example,
and they're going to share equally in the profits.
All right?
So one example would be a firm that they both earn.
They both betrayed,
they both own.
And another example would be two of you working as a study group on my homework
assignment.
All right?
All right,
so you're going to share equally in the profits of this,
of this firm or this joint projects,
but you're going to supply efforts individually.
All right?
So it's just be a bit more formal.
So the players are going to be the two agents,
two agents,
and they own this from,
let's call it maybe over this from joint glee
and they split the profits so they share 50% of the profits.
All.
Alright?
It's a profit sharing partnership
and each agent,
each agent is going to choose
her effort level,
every level to put into this firm
to put into this room.
So it could be the other siding as a lawyer,
how many hours
you're going to spend on the job.
So for most of you is decisions will be question of whether you spend 20 hours a
day at the firm or 21 hours a day at the firm,
something like that.
But most of you on your homework assignments,
I hoping it's a little less than that.
And not much less than that.
All right,
so the strategy choices,
we're not going to do it an hours.
Let's just normalize and regard these choices has living in zero to four.
All right?
And you can choose any number of hours between zero and four.
All right,
and just to mention as we go past it and novelty here,
every game we've seen in the class so far has had a discreet number of
strategies.
Even the game when you chose numbers,
you chose numbers.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
up to 100 the 100 sandwiches.
Here,
there's a continuum of strategies.
You could choose any real number in the intervals are four.
It's you have a continuum of possible choices.
That's not going to bother us,
but let's just point out it's there.
So there's a continuum of strategist.
In principle,
you could bill your clients for every,
for fractions of a second or fractions of a minute.
All right?
I'm that's wonder what the firm's profit is given by.
So this,
this partnership as law firm,
it's profit
is given by the following expression
four times the effort of player one plus the Abbot of player two plus a
parameter called call B times the product of their efforts.
All right?
This is that profits and I won't tell you what B is for now,
but that's just,
I mean I won't tell you exactly what it is about.
I'll explain it what,
assume that B lived between zero and a quarter.
Now it's known.
That's what about a variant later.
Alright,
so what's the idea here?
The idea is playing one directly contributes,
uh,
profits to the firm by working as does play a too,
but they also contribute through this interaction term.
How do we think of that interaction term?
How do we think of that term be s one s two when you're working,
when you're working on your homework assignments,
if you're,
if you're proactive and you hand in was just s one plus s two then you might
think,
well,
you might think there's no point working in a study group at all,
right?
If,
if the,
if the products is just uh,
the psalm or a multiple of us,
some of the inputs,
there wouldn't be much work point working in a team at all.
It's the fact you're getting this extra benefit from working with someone else
that makes it worthwhile working as a team to start with.
Is that right?
So we could think of this term has to do with complimentarity
complementarity
or synergy right word these days,
but still synergy and say,
we're going to assume that when you work together there is something to do.
Some of you are good at some parts of the homework,
some of them are good at other parts of the homework and still in this law firm,
one of these guys is an expert on intellectual property and the other one on
fraud isn't it?
All right.
So I've got the uh,
agents,
I've got the strategy set,
I know something about the profit of the firm.
I need to tell you about their payoffs.
All right to the payoffs.
The payoff for player one is going to depend of course on her choice and on the
choice of her partner.
And he's going to equal a half cause they're splitting the profits.
So a half of the profits are half of four times s one plus s two plus B,
s one s two,
right?
He uh,
she gets half of those profits,
but it also costs,
it costs s one squad.
So s one squared is her effort costs.
It's an input costs.
This is the effort cost.
All right?
And similarly,
play two.
Everything symmetric here.
Play a tos payoff is the same thing.
So this term is the same except we're going to subtract off the player two's
athletes squared,
s s t squared.
All right.
And you get the profits of the firm minus the district policy of having missed
all last week.
There's a guy in the fifth row that he's missed too much sleep.
So somebody just nudge it.
That's it.
Good.
Now what?
We will put him on camera.
Just nudge an attic it,
there you go.
Next time we'll use the camera for that.
Okay.
All right.
So we know we have everything we want to analyze this from and to analyze how
things are going to work either when you're working on a homework assignments or
in the law partnership.
And again,
just to make this relevant to you.
I mean this is very stylized of course,
but a huge number of businesses out there are partnerships and do have this kind
of profit sharing rule and do have some images.
So this is a relevant issue in a lot of businesses.
All right,
now we're going to analyze this no secret here.
We're going to analyze this using the idea of best response,
right?
And it's no surprise to any of use and that's where we started the day.
All right,
so in particular I want to figure out what is play are ones best response to
each possible choice of player to one,
figure out what was probably one of the best response for east possible choice
as to of player to how should I go about doing that?
How
should I do that?
So here what we did before was we drew these graphs with propolis is at least
with beliefs of player one.
And the problem here is a,
previously we had only simple graph to draw because there were just two
strategies for player to patch.
It was a gold league or die for the left and the right problem is here that play
player two has a continuum of strategies and trying to draw all possible
policies over an infinite number of objects on the board is,
is more than my drawing can do it too hard.
I'm going to meet some other technique.
How are we going to find out player one's best response?
Somebody
wave your hands on the APP
way,
way back in the corner.
Can I,
uh,
can we,
yeah,
that's an account.
Let's get the mic.
Yeah.
Wait,
wait.
Stand up and wait for the mic to come see you.
How are we going to do it?
How are we going to figure out what pie one's best responses?
Shout loudly.
You can on fund player ones.
Payoffs as a function of player tos of what player to effort is good.
Okay.
So we've doubled that study.
The first step.
We've got that right,
actually we've got that coheres.
Here's player ones.
Pay Off as a function of what player to choose is an what payer one chooses.
So we have that already.
We have player ones pay off as a function of the two efforts and I want to find
out what his player one's best efforts given a particular choice of s two.
Uh,
yeah,
yeah.
Take the derivative with response to uh,
sorry.
Driven with s one.
Take one,
take a derivative and uh,
equals zero.
Oh,
okay.
Okay,
good.
Good.
So we're going to use calculus,
right?
We're going use calc because of one variable.
All right.
What does,
what does changing one variable last one.
How many of you,
uh,
we won't let the camera say,
how many of you have not?
No,
I don't getting show hands at all.
If you have not seen the cult person I'm about to use on the board or,
or more likely,
if you've forgotten it since high school,
don't panic.
All right.
There is a chapter in the back of the book,
I think it's chapter 25 that goes over this.
It refreshes your memory of such calculus.
And if you haven't,
if you've never seen it before,
if you know,
if you haven't taken,
for example,
they call it of math one 12,
come and see us.
We'll probably try and line up a quick calculus lesson,
a special section for those people,
right?
So if,
if what I'm going to do now is,
um,
scary,
come and see us and we'll deal with it.
All right,
so,
all right,
what I'm going to do,
we want to,
we want to take a derivative of this thing.
All right?
We're going to do is we're going to what we're asking the question,
what is the maximum choosing s one
of this profit.
Can I multiply the half by the four to save myself some time?
So I got the profit is to s one plus s two plus B s s two
minus x one squad,
right?
We're asking the question,
what take your thinking as to has given what s one maximizes his expression.
All right.
And as the gentleman at the back said,
I'm going to differentiate and I'm going to set the thing equal to zero.
So I'm almost bound to get this wrong on the board or can you all watch me like
a hawk?
A second.
All right.
So if a differentiate this objects,
I differentiate,
I'm going to find a first order conditions in a second.
All right?
So differentiate.
I'm going to have to still,
and then this s one is going to become a one.
All right?
And this s one here is going to come a plus B asked to and weren't happy with
that.
And this s one squared,
he's going to come a minus two s one.
All right.
That was differentiating and weren't happy with the way a differentiated.
Is this coming back from high school?
The coaches are spending now.
Yeah.
And to make this a first order condition,
I'm going to say at the best response,
but a hat over the one at the best response.
This is equal to zero.
All right.
Yeah.
Uh,
taking to get the guy again.
Oh,
sorry.
Nevermind.
Okay.
It's quite though,
yet you'll write to turn it cause I'm very,
I mean doing it on the board and bring light to make mistakes,
but okay,
so I differentiated this objects.
This is,
this is my first rotation and I said equal to zero in a second.
I'm going to work with that,
but I want to make sure I'm going to find a maximum and not a minimum.
So how do I make sure I'm finding a maximum,
not a minimum.
I look at the second derivative,
right?
Look at the second derivative,
which is the second order conditioning.
So I'm gonna differentiate this object again with respect to s one but in the
hat isn't verus seconds and none of this has an s one and it's that all goes
away and I'm going to get minus two right when it's too,
which came from here minus two.
And that is in fact negative,
which is what I wanted to know,
right?
To find a maximum.
I want the second derivative to be negative.
All right,
so here it is.
I've got my first daughter condition.
It tells me that the best response to s two best response to s two is the s one
has that solves this equation.
But souls this first order condition.
All right,
and we can just rewrite that.
If I divide through by two and rearrange,
it's going to tell me that s one hats or if you like,
that's what,
that's one hat is equal to one plus B s two one plus ps two.
So this thing is equal to play or one's best response given us too.
All right,
now I could,
I could go through again and do exactly the same thing for player too,
but I'm not going to do that because it's everything symmetric.
Okay?
Everyone happy with that?
So I could at the same,
I could do the same kind of analysis but we know I'll get the same answer.
So similarly I would find that s two hats equals one plus B s one
and this is the best response of player too as it depends on player one's choice
of effort.
S one okay,
now I found out what player one's best responses to placet to play a two.
And what play are twos but the best ones,
the supplier one for each possible choice of player two up here and Vicki
critical will to play player one down there.
All right.
Now let's see if I can get a bit further and to get a bit further.
Let's draw a picture.
All right.
What I'm going to do is I want to draw the two functions we just found and see
what they look like.
Okay?
All right.
This is all in your notes already.
I can get rid of it.
Well,
I can do with it some more chocolate.
Okay.
Excuse me.
All right,
so we're going to do is let's try a picture that has
s one on the horizontal access and s two on the vertical access.
All right,
and there were,
there are different choices here.
One,
two,
three and four
for player one.
Here's a 45 degree line.
I'm careful.
I should get this right.
One,
two,
three
for all the possible choices,
possible choices for player one.
Okay.
Now before I draw it,
I better decide what B is going to be.
Okay,
so I'm going to draw for the case.
I'm going to draw the best response of player one and I want to draw the best of
entrepreneur to in a minute for the case.
Okay?
B equals a quarter,
okay?
So we said B was somewhere between zero and a quarter.
That's draw the case for B equals a quarter.
All right?
Until the expression I want to draw first of all is the best response of player
one as a function of s two and we agreed that that was given by one plus a
quarter.
Now one plus a quarter s t.
All right,
so for each possible choice of s two I'm going to draw player ones.
Best response,
I'm going to do it in,
right?
So if player to choose is zero,
if player to choose is zero,
what does player one's best response?
Let me shout out one.
Okay,
so one pass,
a quarter of zero is one.
So pay a to choose a zero player.
One's best response is to choose one.
Alright?
What if player,
why I play a two chooses for play.
A two chooses for what will be player one's best response.
All right,
so it'll be,
it'll be one plus a quarter times four.
Quarter four is one to one plus one is two.
So a player to as best response in that case will be to sort of pay one chooses
for
Blair to should choose I sorry Claire to choose is for play a one should choose
to.
Right.
And this is a straight line in between.
So the line I've just drawn is the best response for play and one as it depends
on player to his choice.
Haven't happy with how I drew that.
I mean I I I'm assuming you had to take it on faith and a straight lane in
between.
We did.
It's all right.
And the way we read this graph is you give me an s two I read across to the pink
line and dropped down and that tells me the best response,
the player one.
Okay.
And we can do the same for player too.
We can draw player two's best response as it depends on the choices of player
one.
But rather than go through any math,
I already know what that line's going to look like.
What does that line look like?
So many raise your hands.
Somebody,
all the player,
what we'll pay a tos best response look like as a function of player one stress
and the same picture.
Uh,
so we haven't had before all of these guys before.
Someone else,
someone else.
Uh,
yeah,
there's a guy in the,
in the uh,
can,
can we get into him?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Immunity,
diplomat status.
That's pretty right.
Shout out loud to the making heat reflection across 45 degrees.
Right,
exactly.
So,
so if I drew,
if I,
if I drew the equivalent line for player too,
which is play a tos best response for each choice to play a one,
we're simply flipping the identities of the players,
which means we will,
we will,
we reflecting everything in that 45 degree line.
So it'll go from one here to,
to here.
It'll look like this.
So this is the best response for player too,
for every possible choice of player one.
And just to make sure we understand it.
What this Blue Line tells me is you give me an s one and effortless effort level
of player one.
I read up to the Blue Line and go across,
and that tells me player to best response,
okay,
now we're making some progress.
What do we notice when we stayed at one of the lessons of today's class?
The second lesson,
the first lesson was don't shoot towards middle of the goal.
And the second more general lesson was what it was.
Don't have a plan,
a strategy that is not a best response to everything.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm cheating a little bit here because I'm ignoring,
uh,
beliefs,
but trust me,
that's okay in this game.
All right,
so are the strategies here that are never a best response to anything?
We'll stretch his head today,
but all the way,
what stretches of player ones I ever best response
anybody?
Why does have a look?
All right.
If player to choose is zero,
then play a one's best response is one,
and that's as low as he ever goes.
It's as low as he ever goes.
So these strategies down here,
these strategies down here,
less than one,
I'll never a best response for player one.
All right.
And if player to choose these four,
right?
There's,
there's that.
Then the synergy leads player,
uh,
one took to raise his best,
respond to all the way up to two.
But these strategies up here,
you strategies up here above two are never a best response for player one.
Is that right?
So the strategy is below one and above two are never a best response for
planning.
And similarly for player to the lowest player one could ever do is choose zero,
which has player too.
We want to choose one.
So the strategy is below one.
I'll never a best response for player too,
and the strategies above two,
whenever a best response for player too.
All right,
so let's actually,
you might want to be a little bit gentler in your own notebook,
but on my board,
let's get rid of all these strategies that are never a best response.
All right,
so all of these,
all these strategies for player one,
I'd gone and had all of these strategies for player one.
I'd gone,
you might want to not scribble quite so much on your own notebook,
but still.
All right.
And all these strategies for play,
a two are gone and all these strategies for play or two are gone.
And what's left,
a lot of scribble is left.
What's left.
So I claim if you look carefully,
there's a little box in here,
foot box in here
that saw alive.
I've deleted all the strategies that were best,
but I never best responsible player one and all the strategies that I've never
restaurants player too.
And what I've got left is that little box,
but I can't see that little box.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm going to redraw that little box.
Let's redraw it.
So it goes from one to two.
This time I'm going to blow up that box.
So this now is one one and up here is
two.
And let's put in numbers of quarters.
So this will be,
uh,
this will be,
um,
a be baby,
five courses,
six quarters and seven quarters.
Over here it'll be five courses and six courses and seven courses.
And let's just draw how those pink and Blue Line look in that box.
This is just a picture of that little box.
So it's going to turn out,
it goes from the pink line,
goes from here to here
and the Blue Line goes from here to here.
We can work out at home check Kathleen.
But this isn't that correct?
All right.
All right,
well I've done is I've redrawn the picture.
We just had a and blown it up.
And um,
how many you've seen that picture before?
Anyone has seen that picture before?
That's the pitch of we just had,
right?
Except I've changed the numbers of bed.
All right?
Once I deleted once I deleted all the strategies that were never a best response
and just focused on that little box of strategies that survived.
The picture looks exactly the same as it did before.
All big blown up on the numbers changed.
All right,
so what have we done so far?
We said players should never play a strategy.
That's never a best response to anything.
So we throw those away.
All right,
now what's left?
Well,
what's,
what,
what do we do now?
So some of the strategies that we didn't throw away,
work best responses to things,
but the things they were best responses to have now been thrown away.
Is that right?
This is,
this should be something familiar from when we would leading dominated
strategies.
The strategies I'm about to throw away now than not,
it isn't that they're not best responses.
They are best responses to something.
But the things they were best responses to we know are not going to be played
because they themselves were not best for them to stay anything.
All right.
So what strategies do I have in mind?
What flashes I'm about to throw away?
Well,
for example,
for player one,
we know now that player two is never going to choose any strategy below one.
All right?
And so the lowest bio to whatever chooses one and it turns out that the lowest
player two would ever do in response to anything as anything one and above.
It never leaves player one to choose a strategy less than five quarters.
And the highest player to ever chooses is to,
uh,
so,
and the highest response,
uh,
to that play out one ever makes any strategy,
two or less is a sticks quarters.
So all these things bigger than six quarters can go,
let's be careful here.
These strategies I'm about to delete.
It isn't that they never best response is they were best responses to things,
but the things they were best responses to are things that are never going to be
played.
So they were relevant.
Alright?
So we're throwing away all of the strategy is less than five quarters of a
player,
one and bigger than six quarters replay or how much is one and a half by one.
And somebody for play at too.
And if I did this,
and again,
don't struggle too much in your notes,
but if we just make,
uh,
make clear what's going on here,
I'm actually delete these strategies because since I never going to be played,
I end up with a little box again.
All right?
All right,
so everyone,
see what I did,
I started with the game.
I found out what player one's best response was.
For every possible choice of player too.
And I find out what pair of twos,
but best response every possible trusteeship player.
One,
I throw away all strategies,
but we're never a best response.
Then I looked at the strategies that were left.
I said those transfers that were best response to things that have now been
thrown away but not restaurant.
Otherwise I can throw those away too.
I want to throw those away.
I was left once again with the football because I can do it again and again and
again.
I could do it again and again if I go on doing this exercise again and again and
again,
what do I,
what were the,
what am I going to end up with
Saturday night?
What I'm gonna end up with
the intersection,
right?
If I get,
if I keep on constructing these boxes within boxes,
so that next box would be,
would be a little box in here and then draw it.
But it's something like,
like this,
keep on doing boxes within boxes.
I'm going to converge in on that intersection.
So if we know people are not going to play our best risk,
as long as you never best response.
And we know if people are not going to play something,
we just never have restaurants that we were just never a rest response and we
know people are not going to pay us,
which is,
which is not the best one,
that which is not,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
All right,
we're going to converge in,
in this game to just one strategy for each player,
which is where they intersect,
which is where they intersect.
So again,
what we're going to converge in on too is the s one star,
it's called us in this case is equal to one plus B s two star.
And that s two star is equal to one plus B s one star.
All right?
And we actually,
we can do a little better than that since we can let me know.
The game is symmetric.
We know that s one star is actually equal to s to stop.
Alright?
So taking advantage of the fact that we know our s one equalness to cause we're
laying on the 45 degree line.
I can simplify things by making us one star equal to s to stop.
All right,
so now I've got actually that looks like three acquaintances.
We're just two equations.
Does that one of the other players,
the other all right.
And I can solve them and if I solved them out I'm going to get something like,
ah,
let me just,
uh,
be careful.
I'm going to get something like a one minus B s one star is equal to one or s
one star equals s two star is equal to one over one minus B.
And again,
anytime I'm doing Algebra on the board so much and check me at home.
Uh,
so just have a quick look at that.
Is that right?
I think that's right.
All right.
My,
my Algebra,
which is often wrong,
suggest that the solution is s one star equals as two star equals one over one
minus B.
Alright.
[inaudible] this is isn't nothing interesting going on.
I'm just trying to solve that for the equation.
At this point,
okay,
so what do we learn here?
We learned that in this game,
deleting strategies that are never best response and then deleting strategies
that are never best,
anything that's the best response and so on and so forth yielded a single
strategy for each player.
Just one strategy for each player and that strategy was given by this equation.
So if we try,
if we were a management consultants working for Mckinsey or something and we
were brought in to advise you on your homework assignments or this lower
partnership on their work practices,
we would come down with a prediction that this is how much work you're going to
get.
Right?
Question.
Is this amount of work,
a good amount of work or a bad amount of work?
Okay?
It is a good audio here.
All you're working with Mckinsey,
you've been hired by,
uh,
you know,
Joe Smith and,
and blogs to,
to,
to figure out that strategy is working in a problem,
uh,
in a,
a team on working on my homework assignments.
You figured out how much work they're going to contribute.
Is this a good amount of work as this?
Are they controlling too much,
too little?
Of course,
the answer today is depending on compared to what Brian compared to water.
So let me rephrase all these people,
all these pair of partners in the firm or two students working on their homework
assignment,
are they working more or less than an efficient level
to a poll after poll who thinks more?
I think more turn that,
turn the camera and for the world instead of a look.
I think it's more who thinks they're working just right.
Who thinks less,
not of stains?
A lot of stuff of here.
I think they're working to little here.
I think they're working to little here compared to what's efficient.
Uh,
we'll,
I'll get you to solve it out on a homework assignment so you can actually prove
the hat.
You can prove that.
In fact,
if you,
if it was,
if you're writing a contract or if there's a social planner,
uh,
you'd work more.
But let's try and get to grips.
Why?
Why is it that when we see these law partners or medical partners or whatever it
happens to be,
students working together on a homework assignment,
why is it we tend to get inefficiently little efforts when we start figuring out
the strategy and working through the game?
I'm,
I'm conceding the artist.
I'm telling you it's,
they're going to work to referral.
Why do they end up not working harder
enough?
Take us.
Um,
we can get a mic in here.
Yeah.
Yes.
Because if they work any harder than that,
then the other person's just going to slack off instead.
All right.
So there's something about,
that doesn't mean on the other hand,
this isn't really a,
I mean,
the intuition you'll giving me is kind of a prisoner's dilemma intuition,
right?
Saying,
Oh,
I'm going to let the other guy work and I'll,
I'll shook.
But there's something at the end that there's something in that.
But those little bit more going on here,
what's,
what more is going on.
And I think that's good for us to have.
And they're instantly all of that.
Yeah.
If there are two people working together very,
there's about half as much work for each person to do.
That's true.
But that would suggest it doesn't matter if they slack off what's going on here.
So go back to economics one 15 or 150 if you took what either of those courses,
what's the problem here?
What's what's underlying the probiotic that's got to get sky guy in pink down
here,
they only capture 50% of their marginal benefit.
Good.
So when your name is,
so Patrick is giving anyway,
I think it's the correct tone a here.
The problem here isn't really about the amount of work.
It isn't it even by the way about the synergy or you might think it's because of
this synergy that they don't take into account correctly.
That isn't the problem here.
It sounds like even without listening to this problem would be that the problem
is what Patrick said.
The problem is that at the margin I,
a worker in this foam be at a low partnership or a homework,
a homework solving group.
I put you in,
I bear the costs for the at the margin for,
I buy the full cost at the margin for any extra unit of Fla Putin,
but I only reap Hoff the benefits right at the margin I'm reaping,
I,
I'm,
I'm bearing the cost for the extra unit of effort.
I contribute,
but I'm owning reaping Hoff of the,
of the,
of the induced profits of the firm because of profit share.
All right,
and that needs all of us to print you to,
to put in to little efforts or just the general term that captures all such
situations and economics?
It's an externality.
There's an externality.
It wasn't asked analyse when I'm figuring out how much effort to contribute to
this firm.
I don't take into account that other half of profits that goes to you.
So this isn't to do with this,
with the synergy,
it isn't to do something complicated.
It's something you knew back in one 15 right?
If you have profit sharing and affirm or profit sharing and homework assignment
or any joint projects,
you have to worry about too little effort being contributed because there's an
externality.
My efforts benefits you,
not just me.
All right,
and while we've got this on the board,
let's just think a little bit more.
What would happen if we changed the degree of the synergy?
What would happen if we lowered B to B is the degree to which the synergy across
these workers,
if we lowered be what would happen to our picture?
Let me redraw a picture and scribble.
We had a picture that it's something like
this.
All right.
This was s one
and this was as to if we lowered the degree of synergy,
what would happen to the effort level that we'd find by this method?
What would happen?
What happened to the picture?
Okay,
and you already got,
this is a really one 15 and kind of exercise.
We're going to be moving lines around.
Yeah.
A Henry,
isn't it?
So that it's going to make him the,
the lines.
We'll get shallow word eventually become horizontal and vertical respectively.
All right,
good.
So the,
the,
the pink client,
it's actually going to get Steve,
I want to know what you mean.
All right.
So the pink line
is going to move towards the vertical and the Blue Line is going to move towards
the horizontal.
And those is that the amount of the amount of effort that we generate goes down
dramatically.
That's down in this direction.
All right?
So if we lower the synergy here,
not only do I contribute less effort,
but you know,
I contribute to this effort and therefore you can trim it this effort and so on.
All right?
So we get this,
this,
uh,
the scissors effects of taking out of it.
That's why,
all right,
we can draw other lessons from this,
but let me try and move on a little bit.
We decided that this game to Solvay's by looking at best responses,
deleting things that were never a best response,
looking again,
deleting things that were never brushed,
bonds and so on and so forth.
And Luckily in this particular game,
things converged and they converged to the point
where the pink and the Blue Line crossed.
All right.
What's,
what are we,
what do we call that point?
What we call the point where the pink and the Blue Line Cross,
right?
That's an important idea for this class that's going to turn out to be what's
called a Nash equilibrium.
We know what it's cool.
How many,
how many of you've heard the term Nash equilibrium before?
How many of you saw the movie about Nash?
I will come back and talk about that a bit next time.
All right,
so this is a national equilibrium,
but okay,
we know what it is in jargon and we know,
we kind of knew that was going to be an important point because it,
most of you have taken economics courses before and you know that whenever lines
cross and economics,
it's important,
right?
Okay.
But what does it mean here?
Why is it,
what's,
what's going on at that line?
What does it tell us?
What does it tell us that the pink and the Blue Line Cross.
Okay.
What makes that point special way?
What does it mean to say the pink and the Blue Line Cross?
There's a guy,
they're gonna get their way by like three up three rows behind you and purple
shout out.
Again,
it means that neither player has an incentive to deviate from that point.
All right,
well that's that's correct.
That's correct.
So let's try and read that through.
So,
uh,
I don't know your name and they made to,
Alan is saying if play a one,
if player one is choosing this strategy in play,
a two is choosing her stroke,
her corresponding strategy here,
neither player has an incentive to deviate or another way of saying it is
neither player wants to move away,
right?
So if play a one chooses s one star player two will want to choose as to star
since that's how best response and if player two is playing as two star player,
one will want to play as one star.
Since that's his best response,
neither has any incentive to move away.
All right,
so more succinctly,
player one and player two at this point where the lines cross player one and
player two are playing a best response to each other,
right?
The players are playing a best response to each other.
Best response
to each other.
All right,
so clearly in this game it's where the lines cross.
Let's go back to the game.
We played with the numbers.
I'm aware everyone had to choose a number and the winner was going to be the
person who who I was close to two thirds of the average.
By the way,
the winners never picked up my winnings for that,
so they still can.
All right,
so in in that game and watch the Nash Equilibrium in that game.
Yeah.
Everyone,
everyone choosing one.
However one choosing one.
How do we know that the Nash Equilibrium that game?
How do we know that everyone choosing one is the Nash Equilibrium in the game
where you all shows numbers?
Well,
let's just use the definition.
If everybody chose a one,
right?
The average and the cloth would be one.
Two thirds of that would be two thirds and you can't get meat.
You can't go down below one,
so everyone's best response would be to choose one,
right?
Say that again.
So everyone chose one,
then everyone's best response would be to choose one.
Right?
Did that would be a nash equilibrium,
right?
Did people play Nash Equilibrium when we play that game?
Well,
they didn't.
Not at least not initially at any rate.
But notice as we played the game repeatedly,
what happens as we came and played the game repeatedly,
we notice that play seem to converge down towards one.
Is that right?
And in this game,
when we analyze the game repeatedly,
it seemed like a analysis converge towards the equilibrium.
That's not always going to happen,
but it's kind of a nice feature about now she could ever,
I'm sometimes sometimes play tends to converge that now she could up is going to
be a huge idea from now to the midterm exam and we're going to pick it up and
see more examples on Wednesday.